a baptism from hell and a betrayal
bombshell let's drown our sorrows
together on sweet water secrets hello
river babes
after a mini hiatus we are back with the
new sweet letter secrets after show for
episode 313 chapter 48 requiem for a
welterweight which should have been
called what the hell are you doing
Paulie do you agree tell me in the
comments now today I'll be bringing you
behind-the-scenes secrets from stars
Lily Reinhart and Vanessa Morgan talking
all about the episodes biggest betrayals
Plus I'm giving you a particularly
ruthless round of hisses and kisses
but first let's run through all the
basics of what happened in this episode
with our blue and gold breakdown first
up here comes the brainwashed bride now
according to the mysterious Edgar ever
never Alice is finally ready to be
baptised into the farm and she decided
to whip out her old wedding dress for
the occasion sorry you're right but
Betty as usual discovered that there's
something crazy lurking in this coltie
wedding contract
what kind of baptism requires a signed
release form exculpating the
organization in case of bodily harm or
death through Betty's digging we
discovered something old with an escaped
farmy something new like the fact that
the farm also believes in ascending
Something Borrowed as in time and
something blue which in this case was
Alice's body after Betty pulled it from
the baptism bath
that's right Paulie yeah Alice's own
daughter tried to drown her during this
hellish ceremony
luckily Betty's mom survived but her
sanity is officially gone I'm gonna sell
this house now are you curious to know
what's really going on with the farm
yeah me too then so is Lily Reinhardt so
take a look at what she told me I would
like to know a little bit more about
Evelyn ever and ever but that's the
whole point yeah I want to know more
about her you want to know what's up
with her
what's her father all about how does she
get into this weird power position where
she's kind of like her father's disciple
almost so she's very strange interesting
character I feel like I would like to
know a little bit more about her but
then also that's what keeps it
interesting because that you don't know
that much she's growing on me
she's growing on you you like her I
don't like her she's so weird it's open
sorry I don't trust her at all right
right I like her like don't know you
will emerge into the light of your
destiny we haven't met Edgar yet not
okay any any updates on that what should
we now he's coming he's coming
314 whoa I think they'll be coming
around I don't know any I don't know
who's been cast yet but I know it's a
forty-year-old looking good man good
good looking man probably like trusting
eyes probably like kind eyes yeah you
know something's up but you know he's
creepy deep down just like everyone else
in Riverdale and I couldn't even find a
photograph I've had forever never not
one now we all know that One Tree Hill
actor Chad Michael Murray is the man
with the kind eyes who will be playing
Edgar ever never and although I hate to
admit it I feel you Alice I'd let that
face brainwash me too I'll be seeing you
moving on here's the rest of our mini
breakdown of what else happened in this
episode Veronica continued to meddle in
adults affairs because well honestly I
don't know why anymore but she tried to
get her family out of the drug I mean
candy business so that Gladys Jones
could have it all to herself
I'm freaking moving Anton gang news the
gargoyles who used to be Ghoulies have
now been
rooted to the Serpent's sooo bad can you
imagine trying to say that sentence to
someone who doesn't watch Riverdale I
breathed this show and it still sounds
insane meanwhile Cheryl has taken over
the pretty poisons and created an army
of bow wielding minimis but she took
things too far when she unleashed her
girl gang onto innocent things and sweet
pea time to show Chuck hood just how
poisonous we pretties can be Tony was
pissed and promptly put her babe back in
place and regained control of the group
but who knows if that'll last lastly our
Chi is fully into boxing now and
although he originally agreed to throw
his first fight and lose to Ellie OS
dude on purpose Josie helped him see
that he's better than that that sounds
she Archie put up a good fight but in
the end he's still technically lost but
he won in another way which leads us
straight into seven seconds in heaven oh
all you are chose 'if Ann's out there
must have loved this episode because it
was jam-packed with hard eyes flirty
words and our first full-on makeout sesh
but to be honest I was very distracted
during their first big smooch why well
because Archie just got clocked in the
face multiple times and should have been
in a ton of pain so the fact that he was
nose to nose with Josie just moments
after his fight was too unbelievable to
me and once again I live this show so if
this is what struck me as too
far-fetched something is seriously awful
are you serious
as for our other couples I don't have
anything to report Reggie was completely
m.i.a from this episode so there was no
veggie bug head barely spoke and I'm
worried a phallus even exists anymore
okay and Shoni was seriously butting
heads which now leads us into hisses and
kisses first up I'm sad to say this cuz
we literally just met them but hisses -
the pretty poisons or rather hisses -
what Cheryl was making them do in the
first episode ladies
introduce yourself beating up fangs and
sweet pea for no reason and using them
like a scratching post is a big history
me plus its brand new but it seems like
this new girl gang is proving to be
pretty poisonous to Sheryl and Tony's
relationship especially now that we know
that Tony has her eyes on a different
crown and you want me back in the
Serpent's make me queen
now here's what Vanessa Morgan told me
about how she really feels about the
serpents and Tony's future I know you
love being part of the Serpent's you as
Vanessa you loved your jacket are you a
little bummed I am it's kind of like an
emotional thing for me it's like I
became obsessed with the serpents and I
love the serpents and I still feel like
I am a serpent I don't think the
serpents are over for Tony I have no
idea what the writers have in store but
I mean she's bloodline I just I can't
envision her not going back to that it'd
be really cool taking in corporate maybe
both like both gangs and you know they
had the girl gang combined with still
being part of the serpent so where does
this leave Tony and Jughead I think it
leads Tony and Jackie at a place where
they were super close and on the same
page and you know Tony was struck heads
first Veronica South Side and they have
that connection and I think this is
obviously causing a lot of problems for
them I think Jake had realized he
shouldn't have ever kicked her out and
that was a mistake and I think Tony's
trying to hold strong on it yeah I'm
like I want to be the queen of the
serpents and if I'm coming back so it's
just butting heads at this point I know
both being too stubborn people as you
know Jughead and Tony are very similar
and then episode 13 for me personally I
liked how Tony is tough again I find
she's kind of let the relationship take
over and she's been a bit softer and
finally she's like holding her ground
and being tough and for me that's my
favorite part of Tony this season yeah
it's been nice to see her if I loved and
of course we love Cheryl and Tony
together but yeah it's nice to have her
get back to her get back to the roots
and then being able to figure out how
she can be strong and have a
relationship at the same time like you
know so what does this mean for a sweet
bean things I don't know I think it's
one of those things where it's like
sometimes you know when you're best
friends with somebody in the other
falling out but then you're gonna have
that moment of like coming yeah yeah Amy
I really hope that I see that from Tony
or Tony going up to them being like
I miss you guys what do you river rapes
Inc do you want to see Tony back with
the Serpent's tell me in the comments
below but now let's keep it going with
hisses hisses - the fact that Hiram is
back and - the fact that Hermione is
refusing to stand up for herself once
again and while we're on the subject of
Lodge family frustrations hisses -
Veronica because I no longer care about
her relationship with her parents I'm so
tired of this back and forth with them
because nothing's actually ever evolving
anymore
no comment hisses - the farm for being
so ruthless and nepali first straight up
trying to drown her mother if mom dies
and her blood is on your hands Polly oh
and Evelyn I may be intrigued by you but
if you keep messing with my baby Kevin
Keller then we're gonna have an issue
she even said she'd introduced me to
some cute gave armies lastly hisses -
Archie storyline so far in season 3 he's
either kissing a girl he's shirtless or
he's getting attacked friends foes bears
heck one time he was even shirtless
while kissing a girl and then he got
attacked
and now with this welterweight thing
he's actively choosing to get the crap
kicked out of him look red I know that
if you're choosing to fight your demons
this way that's cool I love it
I'm here for you I'm just tired of
seeing you on the brink of death every
other episode okay yeah well just don't
go messing up that pretty face Andrews
switching over to kisses that first one
is going to Betty for saving her mama's
life daughter of the year am i right
yeah
kisses to Tony for acknowledging that
when Sheryl gets a little power-hungry
she needs to step up and put her babe
back in place I missed the old Tony so
this was actually really nice to see is
this gang mine or yours it's yours
kisses to Josie for always keeping it
real with Archie and the Gladys for
being a breath of fresh air in this town
unlike Hiram she makes me laugh so I'm
more inclined to root for her evil deeds
instead that is awesome and kisses to
the fact that there was no gargoyle gang
faked out this week yes in fact there
was barely any Griffins and gargoyles
too well except for when Jughead entered
that creepy game den looking for
what's-his-face are you Kurt and we're
done thank you all so much for watching
the Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 313 and be sure to check back
with me next time for our preview for
episode 314 chapter 49 fire walk with me
for more scoop from the cast on what's
to come but for now if you had fun with
me going down this Riverdale rabbit hole
please give this video a like hit
subscribe and then get your pretty
little booties down to the comments and
unleash your poisonous thoughts what
were your kisses and kisses for this
episode do you agree with Lily are you
intrigued by Evelyn ever never what did
you think about Vanessa's interview do
you miss seeing Tony in the serpent's
share your thoughts with me and I'll see
you next time river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]